[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire à vis de vous retrouver pour
cette quatrième saison et le débat de ce
soir c'est la chute de kaboul qui nous
en dit la trame comment expliquer en
effet la débâcle américaine en
afghanistan en dépit des centaines de
milliards dépensés dans une occupation
militaire qui aura duré vingt ans et
plus généralement pourquoi les
occidentaux ne sont ils plus capable de
gagner une guerre que ce soit en somalie
en afghanistan en irak ou au mali c'est
chaque fois la même chose on gagne au
début on proclame la victoire et puis
les choses tournent à notre désavantage
le chaos s'aggrave et ça va de mal en
pis pour en débattre nous avons invité
gérard chaliand qui est géostratège
spécialiste des conflits armés des
relations internationales vous êtes
rendu très souvent en afghanistan comme
en irak ou en syrie vous avez enseigné à
l'ena l'école de guerre à berkeley à
singapour avait écrit de nombreux livres
j'en citerai trois sur le sujet qui nous
occupe ce soir l'impasse afghane c'est
est paru en 2011 aux éditions de l'aube
pourquoi perton la guerre un nouvel art
occidental c'était chez all dit jacobs
en 2016 et le dernier paru des guérillas
au refus de l'occident qui est sorti en
2020 aux éditions passé composé alors
juste en une phrase pour résumer gérard
chaliand pourquoi est-ce qu'on perd
toutes les guerres votre ami
d'abord parce que l'adversaire nous
connaît on les gagne et autrefois parce
qu'on arrivait avec un matériel
industriel inconnu des idées inconnu par
exemple l'état nation et les types
comprenait même pas comment ça se fait
que ces gens qu'on avait connu deux
trois siècles avant et qu'on pouvait
battre c'était le cas par exemple des
ottomans et d'un seul coup il arrive et
ils sont absolument mais supérieure
pourquoi comment il a fallu trois
générations pour comprendre le
fonctionnement des occidentaux une fois
qu'ils ont compris que et bien voilà la
technique des mecs on ne peut pas les
combattre avec les armes égales il faut
venir à quelque chose qui est très
différent une guérilla longue
avec beaucoup de pertes de l'autre côté
il faut travailler leur moral était du
point de vue moral qu'on s'est effondré
on s'est effondré du point de vue
démographique et l'autre a trouvé
beaucoup dead qui n'existait pas avant
le sanctuaire vous n'en aviez pas au
début rien du tout il n'y avait pas eu
lurçat viatique qui voulut filer quelque
chose où il n'y avait pas un pakistan
qui vous rêvez lui-même il était occupé
donc tout ça c'est un bouleversement
innée elle
pas seulement technologique et en même
temps nous nous arrivions jadis je ne
dis pas que c'est bien ou mal à moi je
sais l'état des lieux que je l'écris les
ariégeois en vainqueur on était sûr que
nous apportions entre guillemets la
civilisation la pensée nouvelle
nous allions modifier le monde et dans
une certaine mesure c'est exact et puis
ça ça s'est effondré au lendemain de la
seconde guerre mondiale on c'est d'une
certaine façon suicidé nous mêmes à
force de nous battre entre nous et
les français se retrouvaient en
indochine dans un combat retardateur
quand les américains sont arrivés sont
libres et les français c'est aux romands
ils ont il n'avait pas le matériel
nécessaire il n'avait pas le souffle est
nécessaire nous analysé kopter on à le
suivre dans l'olympe on est américain et
puis ils sont tombés sur un os sont
tombés sur un os qu est au bout d un
certain nombre d'années ils sont aperçus
que bon il perdait beaucoup de gens
cinquante trois mille hommes aujourd'hui
quand on dit les américains ont bien dû
50 robin hobb gilles macé fantastique en
afghanistan en vingt ans ils n'ont pas
perdu deux mille cinq cents à dire que
la la capacité à encaisser des pertes a
complètement changé aujourd'hui
quand on perd nous par exemple trois ou
quatre types dans le sahel il faut qu'on
les amène aux invalides ou bien
enfin n'importe où d'importants et que
le chef de l'état à les rendre victimes
à novik nous rendrons rendre hommage à
léo victimes ne sont pas victimes et il
était volontaire et se sont battus c'est
leur métier sont victimes de rien du
tout bon donc aujourd'hui une chose très
intéressante l'arrière chez nous
est plus fragile que le combattant on va
revenir là-dessus heures détaille régis
le sommier vous vous êtes journaliste
vous avez été le chef du bureau de paris
match aux états unis de 2003 2009
spécialisé dans les questions
américaines bien sûr mais aussi
militaire vous avez fait de nombreux
séjours en afghanistan et en irak
j'étais encore en avril existe au mois
de juillet dernier vous avez interviewé
george bush barack obama où bachar al
assad vous êtes devenu directeur adjoint
de paris match et aujourd'hui vous
rejoignez la chaîne arte france en tant
que grand reporter je vous souhaite
d'ailleurs les bienvenus j'ajoute que
votre documentaire kaboul au coeur des
talibans a été diffusé hier soir sur
canal+ pour la première fois et qu'il
est toujours disponible en replay alors
même question pourquoi est ce qu'on perd
les guerres à votre avis alors beaucoup
de choses ont été dites je pense que
c'était une virée comment a résumé quand
même très intéressant moi je rajouterais
que en fait on perd les guerres parce
que l'on refuse on ne veut pas on al
impression de confort et pète les mêmes
erreurs à chaque fois de méconnaissance
de l'adversaire vous parliez des états
unis avec le vietnam et c'était une des
premières moi une des révélations que
j'ai eu c'est d'envoyer un documentaire
sur robert mcnamara qui était le le
comment le ministre de la défense
américain pendant la dalle pendant la
guerre du vietnam et qui ce documentaire
était passé dans les années 2000 des
dirigeants était venue l'interviewer en
lui disant mai mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé le vietnam est ce que vous avez et
en fait d'abord on a compris avec ce
documentaire que j ap et mcnamara
n'avait jamais donc les deux adversaires
jamais tant communication le chef de
l'armée ivoirienne jeunes viêt nam yens
et robert mcnamara minix de défense
américains n'avaient jamais de
communication et robert mcnamara disait
j'ai été tellement rare comme buté sur
le fait que c'était des communistes en
face je n'avais pas compris que c'était
des gens qui se battaient pour leur pays
et voilà egia pas eu la même question
quand mcnamara absents fin rencontrés en
1992 donc des années après la guerre et
et mcnamara lui dit mais pendant
l'offensive du têt comment vous avez
fait pour encaisser autant de pertes les
nord-vietnamiens je crois qu'il ya eu je
ne sais pas combien mais dd des
centaines de milliers de morts emma
souvent d'ailleurs des sudètes amiach
qui travaillait pour vienne le dévier de
compte quand voilà exactement et jia
plus a répondu est né parce que c'était
notre pays voilà tout simplement et je
pense que il y a une méconnaissance
finalement des pays et une
méconnaissance de l'adversaire quand les
américains sont allés en irak en 2003
pour comprendre un petit peu déjà la
dynamique junichi je me souviens de deux
commandes séjour avec l'armée américaine
soldat de base il savait pas ce que
c'était il avait même l'impression je me
souviens d'une quelque chose d'assez
d'assez drôle entre guillemets dans le
tragique d'avoir vu un jeune soldat qui
venait à arriver d'arrivée on était dans
un quartier chiite avait des portraits
de l'imam ali de l'imam hussein et ils
disaient c'est fantastique ils sont
tellement accueillants indé portrait du
christ ils nous ont mis des portraits du
christ we7 cette ignorance crasse qui se
double d'une idée et ça je reprend
l'idée que que gérard de on apporte
quelque chose on essaye d'apporter une
civilisation parce qu'on a on est
absolument certain qu'on est con incarne
cette civilisation et on essaie de la
plaquer sur des gens qu'on ne comprend
pas et je pense que fondamentalement il
est là le problème l'afghanistan mais on
a essayé en vain en où les américains et
nous imparfaitement de de faire un pays
voilà un gouvernement qui serait voilà
un peu d'obédience occidentale mois et
en fait on n'a pas compris on n'a
toujours pas compris la question des
tribus on n'a pas toujours pas qu'elle y
compris à l'est qui sont des seigneurs
de guerre on n'a pas résolu le problème
des seigneurs de guerre d'ailleurs c'est
plus un des problèmes principaux en
afghanistan qui ont fait que le
gouvernement aura ni par exemple est
resté si corrompu 6e parce que ces gens
là n'ont jamais quitté leurs prébendes
il
il règne sur des fiefs comme au moyen
âge et si ici on n'a pas et si nous on
arrive en disant on va organiser un jeu
un gouvernement ça va très bien se
passer et puis au bout d'un moment la
démocratie non ça ne marche pas comme ça
parce que ça ne fait pas partie du
logiciel de ces peuples c'est tout alors
comment sont justement par l'afghanistan
lui même qui est l'un des pays du monde
quand même les plus difficiles à
conquérir et même à vaincre trois
grandes puissances s'y sont cassé les
dents
la grande-bretagne au 19e siècle l'union
soviétique au 20e les américains au 21e
à tel point qu'on a baptisé ce pays le
tombeau des empires qu'est-ce qu'il est
particulier à part sa géographie on sait
que ça ressemble un peu c'est les alpes
imaginons la france mais qui serait
couvert par les alpes donc avec des
défilés des petites vallées d ax que ce
serait la raison principale pour
laquelle le l'afghanistan c'est le
tombeau des empires gérard chaliand non
d'abord il ya un bémol qu'il faut mettre
l'expression journalistique tombeau des
empires a été lancé par les américains
en réalité au cours de l'histoire c'est
à dire dans les 800 années qui nous
précèdent les afghans ont été traversés
par à peu près tout le monde ils ont été
traversés par les 1 f talith ensuite
parler un ormeau ensuite par tamerlan
ensuite par les mongols ensuite par des
chinois ensuite caetera et quant aux
engrais ils ont eu une expédition qui a
été écrasée mais 10,1 des anglais ont
rayé dans ce pays pendant un bon siècle
quand cette expédition était écrasée
sétif était partie bêtement l'hiver il
était trop confiants on leur avait dit à
va se passer bien etc ils sont tombés
dans une embuscade
bon il ya eu un rescapé qui est arrivé
jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à nous en sortir
dans la pratique ce qu'on ne dit pas
c'est que trois mois après des anglais
sont revenus divers était fini ils ont
pris kaboul ils ont liquidé les types
qui était dans l' affaire ils ont libéré
les quelques prisonniers blessés et
c'est bon donc quand la guerre commence
en
1978 c'était des combattants valeureux
et d'une totale désorganisation
moi qui avais fait une quinzaine de
guerrier avant j'avais jamais vu un tel
bordel qui on va sur synthétique cette
fouille il n'y avait pas les soviétiques
encore entre eux ils ont été très
mauvais alors les soviétiques sont
arrivés en gros qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire des soviétiques
ils se sont fait des illusions sur ce
qu'ils apportaient il avait amené par
exemple pas mal de musulmans des ouzbeks
et ses appuis soit rendu compte que
finalement ça les embête est de tuer
d'autres musulmans bon ensuite
la remarque qui a été fait selon
laquelle on ne connaissait pas
l'adversaire il n'y a pas que les
américains ils connaissaient pas
l'adversaire il ya aussi les russes ils
sont fait des illusions sur l'adversaire
nous avons par exemple les américains il
avait un type qui s'appelait bernard
salles vous savez tous il a écrit des
bouquins 76 l'ironie ça constamment
match d'ailleurs dans vos livres vous
c'est le type qui a oui c'est le type
qui avait tout il a écrit voilà pourquoi
nous allons être vaincu on navigue en
indochine et il est mort en 67 et ils
avaient tous dit mais là pas été écouté
j'ai rencontré sa veuve elle a dit ben
voilà il était reçue mais tout ce qu'il
disait on n'en tenait pas compte voilà
donc il ya des spécialistes mais on les
écoute pas deuxièmement dans que les
russes arrivent ils essayent de se
battre sérieusement il avait ce qu'on
appelle d'espèces date c'est-à-dire des
troupes d'assaut
des commandos parachutistes
ils ont peiné sur le panshir mais
ailleurs il était très bon mais enfin
ils sont rendus compte que finalement ça
marchait pas ils se sont retirés en bon
ordre
ce que l'on ne rappelle pas assez
souvent ils ont placé au pouvoir à type
qui s'appelait najibullah qui était alex
des services spéciaux mais qui a dit le
marxisme c'est fini j'appelle à une
union nationale il a tenu le pouvoir
pendant deux années et demie aucune
ville n'est tombée pendant qu'il était
là et il était connu parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas corrompus j'ai vu moi sa
photo en afghanistan dans les années
2000 j'ai dit mais comment ça se fait
que tu as la photo de najib ou là on m'a
dit parce qu'ils n'étaient pas corrompus
et ça vous le rappeler
nous nous passions pour des gens qui
soutiennent un gouvernement corrompu et
incompétent
totalement inefficace et comment
dirais-je impopulaires alors quand on se
présente comme des libérateurs des gens
éclairés et c est qu on soutient de
façon évidente des exploiteurs
c'est facile pour en face le dire on va
écouter ils combattent ils combattent
contre nous mais ce sont quand même des
gens qui soutiennent des
exactement ça moi je souscris totalement
à ça je pense que l'humiliation qui est
en train de subir les américains sont en
train de subir des américains
aujourd'hui en afghanistan est d'une
ampleur bien pire que celle qu'ont subis
les russes parce que ce que en fait tu
lis pourquoi en gros le gouvernement
najib ou là qui était quand même qui
avait tourné le dos au communisme qui
restait quand même dans la sphère de
l'union soviétique pourquoi ça s'est
arrêté en 91 parce que l'urss s'est
arrêtée en 91 et que les soutiens
militaires que les russes apporté à
l'armée najibullah quatre cent mille
hommes comme un outil qu'ils aient
laissé sur place mais diboula je
rajouterai aussi par rapport à ce que
vous avez dit c'est qu'il a remporté des
victoires contre les moudjahidine
notamment dans la zone de djalal abad
dans des territoires très complexe ils
ont obtenu des grandes victoires donc
c'est quelqu'un qui était bas qui tenait
le pays avait une administration y avait
des universités y avait des choses que
les russes ont laissé nous qu'est ce
qu'on fait enfin les américains ont re
donne les clés exactement aux mêmes gars
qu'on est venu combattre et chasser il
ya vingt ans et en est sans quoi rien du
tout est-ce que vous parliez de des
mille milliards de dollars investis par
les américains ou peut-être plus
quel héritage tangible des américains
aujourd'hui alors on dira oui
l'éducation de des femmes dans certains
milieux et dans certaines zones urbaines
oui les hasards à ont bénéficié par
exemple de l'occupation américaine
puisqu'ils ont accordé le droit de vote
à leurs femmes alors que les autres ne
l'ont pas les lézards ont vraiment
essayé de tirer leur épingle leur
épingle du jeu je rappelle que pour
préciser les hazaras ondées sont une
ethnie ou chiite qui est qui habitent
dans les montagnes asiatique donc et qui
a tendance à être en opposition avec
beaucoup d'autres ethnies en afghanistan
mais si vous voulez à part ces quelques
et quelques femmes éclairé des gamines
qui ont pu être éduqués enfin qui ont pu
recevoir une éducation à kaboul dans
certaines zones il n'y a rien qui s'est
passé en afghanistan l'important est
qu'ils ont été incapables de créer un
état quel qu'il soit ni d'
administration quelle qu'elle soit et
l'argent a donc servi la corruption mais
aussi les entreprises américaines mais
sur les entreprises américaines mais
elle a servi ce qui est ce qui est
effrayant dans la société afghane
aujourd'hui je sais pas si les choses
vont changer fondamentalement là on est
dans un tournant mais c'est que
n'importe quel fonctionnaire est
corrompu le policier qui fait la
circulation prélève de l'argent
escroquent enfin c'est un un véritable
système dans lac et dans lequel la
corruption est enracinée et ça les
talibans ont remarquablement joué
là-dessus avec vous citiez najibullah
mais les des talibans on s'en passer
pour cette force non corrompu intègre
réintègre qui administre la justice
dallas relativement simple nous quand on
parle de la charia on se dit bah oui la
charia on coupe les mains on les types
ont fait des lapidations etc ces
barbares après que ça fait
l'administration de cette charia là le
paysan de base il la voit très peu il
voit simplement que la justice dallas
dans la dans la cour de l'achat de deux
de la charia moi j'ai eu l'occasion en
juillet de d'assister à une cour de la
charia par les talibans le la justice le
lendemain elle est délivrée c'est plus
et plus la justice de kaboul où il
fallait attendre trois semaines un mois
pour avoir un verdict voir donner un
billet au juge et ensuite on emportait
le truc la sepur et en plus ça vient
d'un l'a donc dans les milieux
traditionnels et dans les milieux ruraux
les talibans ont humé une c'était partie
gagnée il ya aussi une chose qui
explique leur victoire c'est qu'ils ont
cette fois ci à la différence de la
dernière fois où ils ce sont ces neuf
ans yves qui est venu du sud en 96 c'est
à dire des zones pachtoune
essentiellement contre ce qu'on appelle
les hommes du nord c'est-à-dire les
tadjiks des ouzbeks les hasards à la ils
ont réussi là ils ont fait une offensive
au or et il avait des appuis parmi ces
minorités c'est à dire qu'en fait il le
taliban 2.0 si on peut l'appeler comme
ça où le nouveau talibans il a réussi à
conquérir d'autres d'autres populations
que les populations traditionnelles
pachtoune dans lesquelles il a le
mouvement est né voilà gérard oui alors
ils ont effectivement appris beaucoup
c'est à dire que l'échec d'hyères
grâce aux pakistanais est ce que le
pakistan est un état tout de même
relativement avancé ils les ont armés et
idéologiquement en les envoyant dans des
métrés ça c'est à dire des écoles
coraniques deobandi c'est-à-dire très
très dur deuxièmement ils ont entraîné
militairement ils les ont comment
dirais-je formés et ils les ont balancés
et il avait énormément de de gens parce
qu'il ya des millions de pachtouns du
côté pakistanais ailleurs en général
quand les anglais s'en vont de quelque
part ils assurent une bombe à
retardement c'est une partie des
pachtouns du côté pakistanais une partie
du côté de l'afghanistan alors cette
formation
ils les ont en quelque sorte
sophistiqués
aujourd'hui les talibans il ya des
erreurs qui ne vont pas faire ils savent
très bien que s'ils veulent un peu y
être intégrés dans le système
international
il faut qu'ils fassent pas de velours
ils vont y aller doucement ça ne change
pas le fait qu'ils vont appliquer la
charia mais enfin il faut voir comment
on l'appliqué
l'avantagé de la charia dans quand vous
étiez dans l'opposition c'est que vous
donniez la justice vite
on parle des mois avec
pas de corruption on n'achetait pas le
juge et en plus la peine c'était des
peines en général traditionnel
c'est-à-dire que en milieu rural ça ne
vous étonnez pas que ça se finisse de
telle façon en plus ils n'ont pas forcé
il fallait pas qu'ils soient trop
coercitif parce que si vous voulez
gagner de la popularité
il faut être plutôt populaire que
comment dirais-je terrorisant donc ils
s'en sont très bien sortis juste un
point pourquoi est-ce que le pakistan
intérêt à soutenir les talibans ses
vis-à-vis de l'inde alors ceux qui le
disent eux les pakistanais c'est nous
avons besoin d'un arrière stratégique
contre l'inde dans la pratique je pense
que ils ont joué un jeu anti américains
de façon comment dirais-je très perverse
d'une main ils recevaient de l'argent
américain pour
se développer et de l'autre les services
secrets aïe aïe aîe donner de l'argent à
ceux qui allaient tuer des américains ou
des amis des américains donc ça a
fonctionné comme ça et quand les
américains se sont rendu compte par
exemple que ben laden était planquée
depuis dix ans optis d'envieux il ya un
mois au pakistan ils sont dix valeurs en
somme on nous prend pour des crétins
quoi voilà ils sont rendus compte de ce
double jeu mais bien bien tard donc ça
c'est très important
les pakistanais sont les grands
vainqueurs de cette affaire et les
talibans alors vous voulez quels
changements pour vous régis le sommier
alors les talibans c'est intéressant
quand j'ai passé quelques jours avec eux
donc avec une groupe de talibans qui
étaient aux portes de kaboul dans la
province du wardak
ce qui est très intéressant c'est qu'un
certain nombre de jeunes taliban fins de
jeunes combattants parle anglais et dans
un anglais assez sommaire mais je leur
ai demandé comment ils parlaient anglais
et ils m'ont expliqué qu'en fait
certains avaient été à kaboul a fait
avait fait des études à kaboul et puis
qu'en sortant de lait des études il n'y
avait pas de boulot et que du coup ils
sont retournés dans leurs villages et
les avantages des talibans avec leurs
organisations ce qu'ils ont mis en place
c'est qui paye les combattants donc tout
simplement là il ya un côté opportuniste
aussi l'argent et la guerre c'est
toujours très proches il ya à la fois il
ya le coup non le côté ce que peuvent
afficher les talibans en termes de
pureté et ses stars mais en réalité et
quand même énormément de deux d'échangés
de 2 comment et de flux monétaires et là
les talibans en particulier dans le
wardak avait pris possession de mines
ils ont laissé les entreprises continuer
à
faire du business y compris avec le
gouvernement il ya toujours à se côtés
pour eux me léguer à la guerre la
réclamait le business et donc ces jeunes
en fait grâce à cet argent ils ont pu
financer beaucoup leurs combattants
mieux payés parfois que l'armée afghane
ce qui lui permettait même de retourner
des seuls louis l'armée invite à faire
mais régulier avec l'armée afghane au
pareil c'était de traiter l'excès
inverse c'est à dire on n'a pas été
payés depuis trois mois ça fait un an
qu'on est là on n'a pas pu voir nos
familles enfin des types abandonné à
gaza trois ou quatre a gardé un piton
rocheux sur la route de jalalabad la
fameuse route du kaiser passé et donc
exposé à tous vents et qui ne savent pas
très bien alors donc ce qu'ils foutent
là donc en termes de motivation de cette
armée afghane la c1 c'est un vrai point
on en a beaucoup parlé pourquoi trois
cent mille hommes équipés par les
américains pourquoi ce sont pour 83
milliards par an depuis 2000
pourquoi pourquoi ces gens ont pu céder
face à 75000 talent immense et très
simple à partir du moment où en février
2020 les américains font l'accord de
paix avec les talibans et prom est
finalement de se retirer
les afghans les toutes les unités
afghanes savait qu'elle n'aurait pu
l'appui aérien des américains que de
toute façon on n'arrêtait pas de leur
dire qu'un jour ou l'autre des talibans
en prendrait le pays pourquoi dès lors
mourir pour l'afghanistan si de toute
façon on sait que l'issue du combat
voilà donc quand les talibans sont
arrivés là aussi ils ont joué de la
modernité c'est qu'ils ont utilisé les
réseaux sociaux pour diffuser
massivement des vidéos où on voyait les
soldats afghans se rendent et les
talibans les embrasser en leur disant
venez et il fit promettait évidemment
dans le même temps le creux zabihullah
le porte-parole disait mais nous nous
pardonnons à nos frères etc etc alors on
sait pas très bien il ya quand même eu
quelques massacres mais voilà mais ça
c'était pas là et donc ils mettaient en
avant ça donc ils ont extrêmement bien
joué et des réseaux sociaux dans le but
de démoraliser parce que là bas aussi la
grande différence par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé avant et elle à l'époque qui
près de 1000 1 si vous avez les réseaux
sociaux vous avez les smartphones
également sur le taliban 2.0 il ya une
chose qui est très intéressante c'est
que le visage de la musique l'islam qui
professent c'est un islam qui interdit
des instruments de musique donc ceds et
des chants a capella comme l'état
islamique et faisait avec les ânes
hashid etc etc là ils transforment ils
transforment leurs voix avec les vocoder
qu'utilisent les rappeurs du monde
entier donc ça fait des voix trafiquée
et en fait c'est presque des
instrumentaux et il met ça à fond sur
leur moto et sur la moto ils ont des
petites enceintes hyper performant
dernier cri etc et voilà le talibans
d'aujourd'hui il écoute ça il fait de la
musique
bon après il ya des petites voiles à
part quand on dit oui ils sont
extrêmement extrêmement dur sur la
doctrine certes mais bon moi au bivouac
j'en ai vu qui fumaient discrètement
mais bon ils nous ont pas interdit de
cigarette non plus donc c'est c'est un
peu voilà alors maintenant est ce que
une fois qu'ils auront pris le pouvoir
ils vont recommencer mais je suis pas
sûr comme vous disait vous avez raison
c'est ils veulent participer du concert
des nations ils ont déjà des contacts
avec les russes avec les chinois là
encore c'est un pays exempt pas
tellement mais il n'y a pas de y'a pas
d'argent qu'ils ne vont pas reconnaître
l'erreur de devenir un état paria et du
coup un sanctuaire maintenant la vraie
question avec l'état islamique et on le
voit aujourd'hui c'est en gestation
c'est les talibans c'est ça tout près de
là vient distance vous me connaissez
mieux que moi c'est là la complexité à
tenir ce pays et est ce que les talibans
auront la possibilité on voit déjà que
le pan le jir leur échappe toujours mais
pourquoi je sais la géographie comment
fabrice balanche qui est qui et qui est
géographe disait la dcri je trouve être
très intelligemment 7 10 et la revanche
de la géographie enfin et c'est çà et là
le problème de des talibans c'est que
maintenant les gars vous êtes au pouvoir
qu'est ce que vous allez faire des zones
de l'est est ce que vous allez pouvoir
les contrôler là où je rappelle des
choses s'étaient même implanté
territorialement et c'est là où c'est la
raison pour laquelle les taliban ont
combattu des jeux parce que des
chaussettes apparu comme un groupe rival
pas pour des raisons idéologiques mais
dont qui donc ces zones là sont
extrêmement difficile à contrôler et
tout un tas partie du pays comme ça qui
sont extrêmement et c'est un pays de
vallée si on veut comprendre
l'afghanistan il faut comprendre que
c'est des vallées dans lesquelles des
hommes ont vécu quasiment sans aucun
contact avec la vallée d'alasay côté
voilà on fait une pause et puis on va se
demander pourquoi est-ce qu'on perd
toutes les guerres parce que c'est pas
seulement en afghanistan un que ça nous
arrive jeudi nous les occidentaux pause
on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
la fed pourrait bien refermé le robinet
la majorité de ses membres se disent
favorables au taps ring une réduction
des achats d'actifs aujourd'hui on est
dans quelque chose qui ne peut pas être
modifiée vous êtes obligés d'en remettre
à chaque fois un petit peu plus
l'économie réelle est le suis pas donc
c'est le moment de communiquer au saut
modo de faire comprendre à tout le monde
dont cette politique elle pose des
problèmes on est en train de mettre
l'économie réelle à risque on la soumet
vraiment un risque important les banques
centrales aujourd'hui son market
dépendantes et uniquement martel
l'époque donc si elles ne veulent pas
aujourd'hui réduire leurs achats c'est
tout simplement parce que elles savent
très bien que le jour où elle annonce
seront réellement une réduction de leurs
achats les marchés vont s'effondrer
est-ce qu'à une période de stabilité en
haïti est ce que ça a été est ce que ça
existe et je la fais plus de cent ans
que l'on avait assisté à l'assassinât
d'un président de la république d'haïti
l'état de droit a été véritablement mise
à mal pour permettre l'assassinât sur un
mode de crapuleux on a vu en fait se
constituer des armées privées qui
aujourd'hui ont totalement perdu le
contrôle de leur trou et lorsque ces
gangsters sont recrutés par des hommes
politiques ça vous donne une situation
pratiquement de guerre civile nous
sommes ici au coeur d'un système
extrêmement un briquet d'intérêt à la
fois intérieure et extérieure de toute
façon
mafieuse cela ne peut que contribuer à
la dé construction d'un état moderne et
démocratique
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat avec gérard
chaliand l'auteur de pourquoi perton la
guerre un nouvel art occidental c'est
est paru chez odile jacob et de des
guérillas refus de l'occident qui est
paru en 2020 j'ai passé composé est
régis le sommier dont le documentaire
kaboul au coeur des talibans est
diffusée actuellement sur canal+ alors
pourquoi perton les guerres vous le
disiez tout à l'heure gérard chaliand
pendant deux trois siècles les
occidentaux ont remporté toutes les
guerres qu'ils ont mené que ce soit en
asie ou en afrique et puis depuis le
vietnam parce que le tournant c'est le
vietnam a d'abord la guerre d'indochine
que les français perdent militairement
puis les américains s'en mêle et en
dépit des tonnes de bombes qui vont être
déversé des millions de dollars dépensés
des cinq cent mille soldats américains
stationnés au même moment en 1969 au sud
vietnam il ya cinq cent mille soldats
américains en dépit de tout ça c'est la
catastrophe est d'ailleurs une
catastrophe une débâcle qui rappelle
qu'on que que l'on revoit aujourd'hui
votre cas mr aziz départ catastrophe est
dit que là les gens qui attendent sur
les reports d'être embarqué avec avec
les avions américains ne seront pas
l'armée qui a été financé par les
américains qui s'écroule face à des
adversaires et des adversaires en
guenilles qui en dépit du fait qu'ils
sont en guenilles ont battu la première
armée du monde ça se répète de la même
manière mais tout ça commence avec le
vietnam voyez c'est quoi le retournement
à ce moment là qu'est ce qui fait encore
et les américains ont conquis qui
réussit aux noix à contenir l'adversaire
et là tout à coup au vietnam c'est fini
on n'est même plus capable de contenir
l'adversaire alors je me souviens de du
président johnson qui avait des c quand
même humiliant d'être tenu en échec par
des petits hommes en pyjama
dans cette phrase ya tout une certaine
façon je méprise bon adversaire et je
m'étonne que je n'arrive pas à les
écraser parce que je ne comprends pas
parce que je ne sais pas ce qu'il motive
on parle de guerre asymétrique bon
qu'est ce que c'est la symétrie c'est à
dire qu'on est plus égaux il ya quelque
chose de décalé la véritable asymétrie
elle est idéologique si je suis prêt à
mourir pour la cause pour laquelle je
combats je ferai toujours mieux que vous
qui faisait toucher votre paye qui
venait toucher votre
mortgage de la baraque que vous allez
acheter aux états unis ou de la carte
verte qui va vous permettre de devenir
enfin sur la voie d'une citoyenneté
américaine il ya une différence
fantastique voilà ça c'est très
important mais il ya aussi moi ce qui me
frappe toujours quand je vois les
soldats américains et on voit comme ils
sont à des sont équipés d'une manière
incroyable font quatre soldats n'a
jamais été aussi bien équipant que les
soldats américains aujourd'hui mais en
même temps quand je les vois je me dis
ces gens là n'ont jamais eu un avion et
demi au dessus de leurs têtes ils savent
pas que ce que c'est que d'avoir un char
en face d'eux au fond ils n'ont aucune
expérience de la guerre totalement fait
qui n'a rien à voir avec le vul
l'expérience qu'ils avaient leur
grand-père face à l'armée allemande ou à
l'armée japonaise exact il se bat contre
des types qui ont souvent les pieds nus
des fusils quelquefois des lance
roquettes
mais cette vision qu'ils ont de la
guerre on en fait les meilleurs
combattants du monde mais dans les
tranchées tiendrait pas dix minutes
par exemple au jeté à un camp
d'entraînement
par les britanniques où il formait des
types qui allait se battre contre les
talibans
alors le l'anglais leur a fait faire
ceci cela puis finalement il à vis
maintenant on va faire des pompes alors
le traducteur dit ok push up achats etc
et les des soldats je suis pas d'accord
comment ça soit ils sont pas d'accord il
dit voilà ils disent qu'ils n'ont pas
besoin de bras pour tenir une
kalachnikov eux ce qu'ils eurent faux cv
jambes et les américains ils ont 30 à 40
kg sur le dos et bien même avec l'argent
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à grimper derrière
nous à la montagne nous sommes tous
seuls la seule expérience qui a eu d'une
comment dirais-je d'une embuscade
américaine a été fait parce que des
gants ont été emmenés
héliporté qu'on l'aurait dit il passe
par là planquez vous personne ne fume et
demain vous allez nettoyer autrement la
poursuite ne se faisait pas quand
crystal général intelligent qui a été
payé par le congrès pour faire en 2008
une
habile ans
il l'a fait il a publié dans le
washington post et il a dit écoute et
90% de nos troupes ne sortent jamais des
bases quand ils sortent c'est en force à
tel point ils ont la trouille qu'il ya
un camion suicide et les bogies donc
aucun contact avec la population
d'ailleurs personne ne l'a d'interprète
il leur a dit cette phrase je vais vous
l'aviez en anglais guys une arène
afghanistan transitent les mecs vous
n'êtes pas en afgha vous êtes en transit
oui voilà mais c'est comme ça des gens
en somalie en 95 c'est d'être semée
d'écueils 6 est bien pire en afghanistan
parce qu'il y avait aussi la laddh dans
ces fameuses bases que cette espèce de
camp retranché mais aussi la recréer les
états unis avec dj hi friday qui était
d'aider des siennes à dornes coeur il y
avait l'équivalent d'un cet avantage est
stable oui d'accord alors moi je
rajouterais une chose par rapport à la
qualité du soldat n'est pas forcément un
mauvais soldats des troupes d'élite qui
sont quand même assez performante mais
je crois que le chiffre dépasse les 80%
des morts dont des 4000 morts d'irak et
des 2500 morts d'afghanistan
80% de ses soldats là n'ont jamais vu
l'adversaire
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont morts par des
bombes posées sous la route et donc
c'est ça aussi ce que vous disiez dans
la première partie l'idée de miner le
moral de l'adversaire et en disant voilà
ils sont insaisissables la guerre
asymétrique elle est peut-être
idéologique je suis d'accord mais elle
est aussi dans la pratique quelque chose
d'épouvantable parce que on voit son
camarade perte ses jambes et à la maison
évidemment l'ombre de choc s fait au
goutte à goutte
c'est plus le 22 août 1914 où la france
perd 27 mille soldats en une seule
journée souvent sans voir l'adversaire
aussi les premiers jours dans les airs
de 14 on ne voit pas l'adversaire voir
et vous voyez pas mais mais si vous
voulez 27 mille morts on a une journée
c'est hallucinant là quatre types dans
le sahel qui vont avoir les vols droit
aux honneurs la cour des invalides et
c'est ça fait beaucoup plus pour se dire
dans la population mais qu'est ce qu'on
fout là bas on est sûr qu'on qu'en plus
il n'y a pas de finalité le terme
utilisé comme on le sait pas mcchrystal
qui en a parlé mais de forever wars les
guerres sans fin c'est c'est aussi ça le
problème de ces guerres compères
pourquoi on les perd parce qu'on finit
par s'user les jambes bush a déclenché
ces deux guerres d'irak et d'afghanistan
sont près de son successeur barack obama
et telus essentiellement pas parce qu'il
est charmant nouveau il ya tout ça dans
la dans la dans la magie d'obama mais
surtout parce qu'il est sur un programme
anti guerre et parce qu'il sait programs
et des soeurs étaient opposés à l'ira et
sur un programme de retrait des troupes
qui va être perpétué d'ailleurs la seule
point commun entre barack obama et
donald trump c'est justement l'idée de
faire venir les troupes à la maison et
là ça pose aussi un problème puisque
barack obama en 2010 décide de retirer
les troupes d'afghanistan d'irak
qu'est-ce qui se passe émergence de
dèche et aujourd'hui donald trump suivi
par joe biden décide de comment de
retirer les troupes d'afghanistan les
talibans reviennent au pouvoir donc on
peut légitimement se poser la question
sommes nous vraiment en train de gagner
cette fameuse guerre contre le
terrorisme
qu'on a initié en 2001 après les lézards
accéder s'il ya une guerre qui est censé
durer l'éternité c'est bien la guerre
contre le terrorisme puisque on se bat
contre un fond simple sûr mais avant
quand on parlait de d'asymétrie bas même
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale il y
avait l'allemagne avec ses alliés et
puis il y avait les états unis avec
leurs alliés le japon pareil et ça se
finissait par un traité de paix sur un
une parade à brooklyn comment une parade
à manhattan voilà aujourd'hui c'est
inimaginable
et toutes ces guerres là les guerres
qu'on a perdu elles ont été enfin qu'on
est en train de perdre donc on a
continué à perdre c'est parce que c'est
des guerres qu'ils n'avaient pas de faim
qu'ils n'avaient pas de deux en fait
qu'ils n'avaient pas de finalité il ya
eu aussi le problème moi je rajouterais
ça aussi essentiel dans ce qui s'est
passé dans les vingt dernières années
c'est le retour de la morale via le
néoconservatisme néoconservatisme qu'une
idéologie qui à l'issue de la guerre du
vietnam d'ailleurs une certain nombre de
démocrates d'ailleurs ce sont ulcérés
par ses pertes du vietnam ont décrété
que la démocratie devait être imposée
par la force que c'était mort on
critique on disait on attend on incarne
le camp du bien et on va montrer au camp
du mal donc il ya eu ce retour de la
morale qui fait qu'un certain nombre de
dictateurs dont on s'était accommodée
pendant des années parlent de kadhafi
par exemple et de saddam hussein pour
les plus proéminents et ceux qui
finalement nous ont donné ces guerre
ingagnable infiné et bien ces dictateurs
pour des raisons économiques pour tout
un tas de raisons aussi sont devenus
tout à coup les nouveaux hitler et ça la
communication est arrivé dans l'opinion
publique il fallait marteler l'idée que
saddam hussein était d'abord un allié
d'al qaïda ce qui n'a jamais aidé alors
là inventer des trucs on a vu ce blog ce
brave colline pauwels eu finalement ce
fut milliers presque en brandissant
cette fiole et en faisant le lien entre
un terroriste obscures qui s'appelait
abou moussab al zarkaoui et saddam
hussein en disant c'est le lien entre
al-qaïda et saddam hussein lien qui n'a
jamais existé et notre saddam hussein
que nous q que jacques chirac appréciait
beaucoup et que les etats-unis
apprécient beaucoup donald rumsfeld et
et elle avait rencontré tout le monde
n'avait rencontré c'était notre part
avant contre l'iran à l'époque tous qui
nous a servi et là tout à coup il ya eu
une bonne idéologique un retour de la
morale le droit d'ingérence c'est joli
ça soigne leur peuple et on y va et in
fine et une fois que le seul m us n est
plus là qu'est ce qu'on met à la place
on voit bien que ça se déroule
pratiquement toutes ces guerres se sont
déroulées de la même manière
effectivement diabolisation de
l'adversaire c'est pardon classe obbadi
c'est la même chose donc on diabolise on
dit qu'il faut absolument intervenir
qu'on va sauver l'humanité qu'on va
sauver la civilisation on intervient en
général on gagne d'abord aussi bien au
mali où on voit françois hollande
annoncé à tombouctou qu'on a libéré le
mali du terrorisme jean yves le drian
qui d'ixelles affaire est réglée comme
george bush en 2004 en irak 2003 dixon
et j25 adlistes voilà une relation et
répondre à chaque fois ça se passe de la
même manière on gagne sur le plan
militaire ou du moins on croit avoir
gagné on proclame la victoire et après
ça va de mal en pis et on s'enlise on
est toujours au mali aujourd'hui comme
les amériques a été toujours en
afghanistan et on y reste et nous aussi
très longtemps ils sont toujours en irak
qui vont peut-être pas resté longtemps
non plus il ya qu'en libye où là on n'a
pas envoyé d'hommes au sol donc là on
n'était pas là mais on n'a fait
qu'aggraver le chaos et le tas de l'état
de la libye voilà c'est une catastrophe
et ça a donné le mali pour l impression
que ça se répète toujours de la même
manière et qu'on n'apprend pas on
n'apprend pas et d'ailleurs on entend la
depuis la chute de kaboul un certain
nombre de gens dire mais en fait il faut
intervenir pour aller sauver les femmes
afghanes comme si on n'avait pas été là
bas pour en 20 ans
absurde et il ya une chose aussi très
important c'est la dimension
démographique c'est à dire là nous nous
n'avons pas les mêmes chiffres moi j'ai
le chiffre de
33 % d'occidentaux en 1900 et
aujourd'hui 13 oui moi c'est 25%
d'occidentaux et et 13 bon de toute
façon on a fondu fut et quand vous
fondez ça veut dire que les autres
augmentent donc vous d'encaisser plus
les pertes comme autrefois aujourd'hui
l'idée aux états unis qu'on puisse
perdre 50 3000 hommes comment ils ont
consenti à y perdre dans les années 60
c'est impensable
bon donc cette une est une donnée très
importante
vous ne pouvez pas entreprendre des
guerres londe difficile sur le plan
psychologique comme une séparation le
plan humain
si vous n'êtes pas décidé à perdre quand
même quelques troupes bon ben nous en
sommes là à dire que quand on en est là
ne fait plus ce type de guerre voilà à
mon avis on n'en verra pas mais comme ça
on est ce qu'aujourd'hui toutes ces
guerres dont on parle est ce qu'elles
sont menées par les militaires ou est-ce
qu'elles sont menées par les politiques
qui commande sont emmenés par les
policiers qu'il filait qui tiennent
compte de l'opinion publique et qui
doivent leur pouvoir au fait qu'ils vont
être réélu ou pas oui ces ratios
s'habiller les généraux ont toujours
tendance à vouloir en rajouter sur les
guerres b in fine et c'est comme ça
reste quand même le politique qui décide
et généralement les zéros enfin moi j'ai
entendu beaucoup de généraux se plaindre
par exemple en france que l'armée
française est envoyé sur trop
d'opérations extérieures qu'elles
n'avaient pas les moyens
l'armée française sur l'afrique alors là
aussi il ya un paradoxe c'est que quand
on est dans le dans le dans l'appareil
militaire quand on a va quand on est
présent en afrique on a quand même aussi
pour notre armée faut voir le un terrain
d'entraînement absolument incroyable
c'était une des raisons pour laquelle au
départ chirac voulait suivre les il ya
eu il ya eu un petit moment où chirac
était d'accord pour accompagner les
américains pour dire en dix ans en irak
guerre pareil oui dans une guerre pareil
on ne peut pas être absent pour ne
serait ce que pour l'entraînement dans
notre armée pour voilà pour être dans le
coup finalement il ya eu un volte face
les français ont fait peut-être l'acte
de politique internationale le plus
courageux je trouve des vingt dernières
années qui a été de s'opposer et de dire
aux américains non nous n'allons pas sur
les bases que nous vous nous vendez
comment intervenir en irak à vos côtés
ça a coûté beaucoup au français cédric
jusque là les français avaient raison
c'est à dire que c'était un montage ya
jamais eu d'armes de destruction massive
entre les mains de saddam hussein n'y a
jamais eu de contact avec al-qaïda et
c'est simplement que les américains ont
fait l'erreur d'un
suprématisme obli peau temps maintenant
que l'union soviétique n'existe plus on
fait ce qu'on veut les années 90 ont été
extraordinaires et nous sommes en 2001
on vient de vaincre
avec un coût dérisoire
les intéristes ans
et tout de suite là les néo
conservateurs disent en fait il faut
préparer l'opinion publique
internationale à intervenir en irak
c'est ça la partie décisive on va
remodeler le grand moyen-orient le seul
truc qui nous manque donc de front en
plus donc de héron est alors en quelque
sorte l'irak veut dire plus exactement
l'afghanistan a été le dégât collatéral
de l'irak il s'en fichait c'était
affaire classée tu es loin la victoire
était totale sauf que les machistes avec
ont remis ça et en 2003 il y avait des
pertes en 2005 il y avait une
organisation sérieuse en 2006 les
américains découvrent qu'ils ont perdu
l'otan 180 aux hommes ça les a inquiétés
bon donc une erreur après l'autre en
s'imaginant que on détenait en quelque
sorte ma foi
l'essentiel du pouvoir et en 2008 il ya
eu cette crise économique très
importante et en 2010 on annonce que à
les numéros 2 c les chinois c'est à dire
que sous nos yeux là le monde a changé
les années 90 c'était l'exaltation
extraordinaire des états unis on fait ce
qu'on veut là où on veut et en 2010 on
nous avertit attention il ya des chinois
est depuis depuis une décennie nous
n'avons pas cessé en sorte de nous
rendre compte d'une chose c'est que
quand il y avait lui au soviétisme
c'était un adversaire
militaires et spatiales
c'est tous savaient même pas faire une
boîte d'allumettes qu'il craque qui
barrent qui marchait bien
les chinois ils savent tout faire ils
sont sur tous les fronts il bosse avec
énormément de comment dirais-je de
philly il n'y a que les japonais pour
faire mieux et mais est-ce que les est
ce que les chinois profitent justement
de cette habitude maintenant que les
américains et leurs alliés les français
légué telling de perdre la guerre parce
qu'on peut se demander à qui ça profite
est-ce que ça profite aux chinois on a
l'impression que ça profite aux russes
au moyen-orient
ils ont tiré leur épingle du jeu du
chaos qui a été semé par les américains
l'iran aussi l'iran a considérablement
gagné en influence depuis que les
américains sont intervenus avant de
s'asseoir cestus enfin les les
américains ont de façon assez stupide
données l'irak à l'iran c'est à dire en
renversant
sanaba saddam qui représentait avec ses
7 sa communauté arabe sunnite 20% de la
population et en donnant le pouvoir 60%
de shit le centre religieux étant l'irak
et le centre politique du monde chiite
est temps l'iran était évident que
l'iran n'avait plus justement ce que je
disais tout à l'heure le le para vente
sa dame qui venait qu'on avait armé et à
une guerre faut pas l'oublier on parle
de la guerre des russes en afghanistan
mais celle entre l'iran et l'irak elle a
fait un million de morts entre 80 même
pendant dix ans entre dans les années 80
donc on s'en servaient comme boucliers
et eu hélas assez stupidement
géostratégiquement on redonne l'avantagé
à l'iran est aujourd'hui en plus les
américains viennent s'en plaindre en
disant ah oui mais les iraniens ils sont
partout avec le hezbollah les outils etc
etc oui mais en fait on leur a quand
même donné largement la main en irak et
ça c'est c'est quelque chose d'assez
dacd voilà c'est quand même une erreur
je trouv in fine et 7,7 et je voulais
revenir sur quand même le dé la guerre
en afghanistan 20 essais il faut quand
même reconnaître qu'au début et vous
vous avez noté assez précisément
justement les années 2003 2005 2008 où
le monde change mais aussi la nature de
la guerre en afghanistan change au
départ faute il faut voir que c'est une
guerre qu'on peut qualifier de guerre de
nécessité
pourquoi parce que il ya ben laden parce
qu'elle sanctuaire parce que la machine
elle est là il faut rappeler que les 11
kamikazes lieu les 19 kamikazes du
11-septembre ont été sélectionnés
entraîné sur les balles sur la
l'amassada c'est à dire le la tanière du
lion de ben laden à kandahar donc c'est
là qu'ils ont été formés et recrutés etc
etc donc c'était là que se trouvait le
coeur de la machine terroriste d'al
qaïda donc il y avait une nécessité de
riposter et quelque part cette guerre
elle a été intelligemment mené au départ
avec
coup de force spéciale appuyons la
fameuse alliance du nord donc les
peuples du nord hostile aux talibans et
au stylo pachtoune donc du sud et donc
ce qui s'est passé c'est que ils ont
fait tomber le régime des talibans en
les utilisant et pendant quelques années
en afghanistan l'activité insurgés elle
a été relativement basse pourquoi parce
que il y avait des forces spéciales et
les afghans qui ne déteste rien moins
que d'être occupés par les étrangers est
pour ça que la contre insurrection de
david petraeus n'a jamais vraiment
marché en afghanistan alors qu'elle a
fonctionné en irak milieu plus urbain
qui a accepté beaucoup plus facilement
la présence d irak d des soldats si si
si ce débat cela était si ceux ci
étaient là pour résoudre les problèmes
de la population
en afghanistan il était impossible
d'aller au coeur des villages il fallait
forcément être sur une base à
l'extérieur donc on ne pouvait pas
vraiment être au contact de la
population et à partir des années 2005
2006 savez le premier attentat suicide
en afghanistan il est en 2007 alors qu
en irak et en a tous les jours donc
voilà pourquoi parce qu'il ya une
augmentation du nombre des troupes
américaines en afghanistan font au fur à
mesure que cette violence onex et les
l'amérique l'amérique redevient un pays
devient un pays occupant comme la russie
et à avant alors qu'au départ bras et
l'irak là on est sur une guerre de choix
la guerre du choix des dirigeants
américains n'y a absolument pas
nécessaire et qui va ouvrir la boîte de
pandore du deal est dispo dans tout le
moyen-orient la déstabilisation de
l'irak ça pour conséquence l'arrivée de
neige c'est avec pour conséquence la
mise à l'écart de la communauté arabe
sunnite irakienne c'est la vengeance de
saddam quelque part et qui va profiter
de la guerre civile syrienne pour
justement contaminer toute la merde
dernière question puisque jeu cette
émission fait référence au titre de
votre livre gérard chaliand pourquoi
perton les guerres vous souhaitez
sous-titré un nouvel art occidental mais
je me demande si ce n'est pas le cas de
toutes les puissances au fond la russie
ne gagne pas les guerres non plus et en
afghanistan n'a pas gagné et la plupart
du temps non plus aujourd'hui on peut se
demander si les taliban ont vraiment
nier en afghanistan depuis ce qu'ils ont
déjà des shs cours eu et il y aura
forcément une guerre civile qui va
s'installer il sera elle non plus ne
gagne pas contre le hezbollah en dépit
de sa supériorité technologique et
militaire et et pourtant il sera utile
ça pourquoi ils combattent
c'est à leur porte c'est à leurs
frontières c'est pas comme les
américains qu'on expédie de d'oklahoma
en atterrissant on a l'impression que
plus personne ne gagne de guerre aux
autres votre déclaration est un peu
provocatrice après tout les soviétiques
n'ont perdu qu'une seule guerre
et ils ont perdu la guerre d'afghanistan
ailleurs non ils ont remis l'ordre à
leur façon à budapest
non je pensais la russie depuis on ne
s'est i dont c'est la première fois que
l'armée rouge reculer et abandonner un
territoire depuis sa création parce que
l'armée allemande l'avait fait reculer
mais elle avait repris tous les
territoires
ensuite israël franchement je veux dire
que israël s'en sort très bien moi je me
souviens avoir travaillé pendant six
mois avec les divers groupes afghans et
je suis allé ensuite en israël nous
sommes en 1970 71 et on me dit ah bah
puisque vous avez passé six mois avec
les palestiniens le type qui est le
patron du mossad voudra bien rencontrer
je suis dit bon moi je veux bien le
rencontrer je lui dirai la même chose
qu'aux autres et alors je rencontre ce
monsieur un type d'une cinquantaine
d'années moi j'en avais trente et
quelques il me dit alors mon garçon
qu'est ce qui t'a dit rafat je dis bah
il m'a dit le temps travaille pour nous
il m'a répondu une phrase que je
n'oublierai jamais me dit quand tu
verras la prochaine fois déduit que le
temps travaille pour ceux qui
travaillent pour lui
israël a travaillé mais reconnaissez
gérard chaliand que contre le hezbollah
israël est intervenue à plusieurs
reprises oui notamment l'automobile ce
jour-là 2006 s'était même mauvais en
2006 on peut dire que techniquement
parlant le hezbollah s'en était mieux
sorti que les histoires il est toujours
là donc ça veut dire qu'il ya pas une
victoire militaire combien une victoire
contre l'egypte en 73 qui a fini par
donner à traiter paix mais il y avait
entre temps entre temps israël a marqué
des points il y avait un tas de pays qui
voulaient même pas leur parler des
arabes qui ont accepté que bon bah voilà
tu existes il faut tenir de ton
existence etc on peut pas dire qu israël
soit un état ultra menacé aujourd'hui
non dans la cmm qui ne gagnent pas qui
ne remporte pas de victoire tellement
plus parce que la victoire ne se
remporte pas seulement militairement
ouais et lui faire se rapporte quand
vous êtes capable de produire de la
croissance par exemple la chose qui
frappe par exemple dans le monde arabe
c'est que très bien vous êtes
d'excellents perturbateurs ou balancer
des bombes ça fait du groupe des
problèmes mais est-ce que puisque vous
avez fait un califat puisque vous avez
prétendu que la frontière n'existait
plus que vous êtes capable de modifier
les conditions économiques réponse non
on ne peut triompher que si on est
capable de faire de la croissance
économique c'est la seule revanche que
vous pouvez prendre sur l'histoire c'est
ce que les japonais ont fait avec la
révolution du bep j en 1868 ils sont ils
ont pris le modèle occidental mais ils
ont réussi à faire de la croissance et
en neuvième après la seconde guerre
mondiale sursis à l'allemagne pareil
exact bon ensuite le comment dirais-je
les vietnamiens qui en avait pris plein
la gueule avec des américains se rendre
compte parce qu'ils sont dirigés par des
despotes éclairés que l'adversaire
principal c'est la pesée extrême de la
chine et qu'il faut se range du côté
américain pour pouvoir sont battus les
chez toi d'ailleurs avoir battu les
américains et les français ils ont battu
les chinois ou en 79 ils les ont
reconduits mama aujourd'hui de puiser
les âmes et les chinois sont devenus
redoutable en tout cas donc l'important
c'est de savoir exactement ce qu'il faut
faire de votre indépendance ou bien au
marché pour une révolution avortée vous
êtes battus très bien bravo moi j'en
connais plein qui sont battus je vais
participer à des guérillas qui ont
finalement débouché sur la dépense peu
après ça a été le bordel absolue la
l'incurie le despotisme regardez par
exemple l'erythrée
c'est une dictature atroce bon
les latino-américains
l'uruguay le type qui a fait la
révolution de 1979 vingt ans après
castro aujourd'hui il fait tirer depuis
deux ans sur la foule parce qu'il veut
rester au pouvoir bon ben voilà c'est
attristant
c'est le mot de la fin rien à ajouter
registre et ce blanc enregistrent
intervenait juste c'est quoi si on peut
gagner une bataille des perdre une
guerre je pense à la bataille d'alger
qui militairement et et gagner
politiquement l'algérie a été perdue peu
de temps après donc il ya aussi des
choses parce que eux ont dit que
politiquement on ne pouvait pas gagner
on n'aime pas mais oui mais alors là on
était dans leur voulu là on ne pouvait
pas gagner cette guerre là on est dans
les guerres de décolonisation aussi on
hérite aussi de de cette décolonisation
qui nous revient comme un boomerang et
voilà vous regardez dans les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi et on se
retrouve au prochain numéro oui
j'ajouterai
[Musique]